un truc tu y es fou en france c'est ce
tabou mais inexplicable autour du poids
je suis désolé on peut dire de la même
manière que moi je le dirai à mon mec
s'il change d'apparence physique pendant
le temps où on est ensemble et qu'il
devient gros parce qu'il fait pas
attention parce qu'il est plus de sport
parce qu'il boit trop de la bière parce
que j'en sais rien je lui dire à un
moment dit donc mec tu as peut être un
peu te détendre sur le poids parce que
moi j'aimerais bien que tu gardes une
apparence physique les volu liriez
j'imagine de façon à faire passer c'est
passé à l'art est pas choquant parce que
je le dirai à un mec et que je lui dirai
un peu comme ça en disant picole un peu
moins un peu de sport dès qu'on aborde
le poids d'une femme en france l'est
encore aujourd'hui c'est un problème
pourquoi cette un problème de dire à une
nana tu as un petit peu grossi fais
gaffe alors que c'est pas un problème de
dire tu as un petit peu maigri fais
gaffe donc moi j'en ai marre de cette
hypocrisie j'en ai marre de sarko débat
vous pouvez pas non plus de nier qu'il
existe de la grossophobie coquille et il
ya des femmes qui souffrent parce qu'on
les montre du doigt et se moquent de
leur poids je ne nie rien du trouve
l'important c'est quoi c'est qu'elle
soit bien dans sa peau elle le dit
pendant tout le long du reportage je
suis bien dans la branche bien dans ma
peau je suis bien dans ma peau
bon bah c'est ça l'important maintenant
les gens qui changent d'apparence
physique soit parce qu'ils grossissent
soit parce qu'ils maigri mais beria
dorian à votre amoureux c'est fini parce
que tu as pris du poids et c'est terminé
entre nous si la différence entre le
moment où j'ai avec lui je trouve qu'un
enfant et dix ans après c'est sûr elle
est quand même là mais on l'aimé on est
nul et non seulement pour le physique
mais aussi pour ce qu'il a le physique
ccc au su du monde et c'est pas juste
une apparence si c'est assez facile
venant de toi qui nous expliquait en p1
que non mais tu peut grignoter tout ce
que je veux de toute façon je crois pas
de toi tu fais de même fois depuis 30
ans donc oui c'est facile de dire bah
oui ben moi mon mec ci prend 1 kg je
vois rigoler du massif c'est ce que tu
es en train de dire mme anna et de me
juger l'injure des habitudes que tu ne
connais pas et qui me demandent aussi un
effort parce que je me suis mal et on
danse qu'elle aime la vie et de ma
rigueur à respecter encore au moins une
fille qui me plaît et ça ne me
choquerait pas que quelqu'un me dise tu
as pris cinq kilos août a perdu cinq
kilos alors j'avoue là ne dit pas oui
bah moi je peux bouffer plein de chips
et j'ai pas de souci je ne grossit pas
parce que du coup je reste et en plus
c'est gros les autres jeunes et si c'est
vrai je n'ai pas
tu dis moi je suis les problèmes dans la
suite des audiences est un sujet pas les
faits on vous entend pas dans le court
je suis désolé moi pour moi par exemple
ma moitié ça fait huit ans qu'on est
ensemble on a toutes les deux gros si je
lui ai posé la question pas plus tard
qu'hier parce qu'effectivement j'ai pris
beaucoup de poids rapport à plein de
choses et ans parce que j'ai travailé
sentent voilà à partir du moment où tu
te sens bien dans ta peau peu importe
pour moi je vois là je tu peux prendre
encore dit quino 20 kilos je m'en fous
et partiellement où tu es heureuse là et
c'est exact des aides mais c'est ce que
je sais c'est pour ça que je dis que le
mec est un connard qu'elle a raison le
quitter si elle est bien dans sa peau
avec ses formes avec ce avec ses
rondeurs
cela ne pose aucun problème est qu'il
permet d'indiquer sa visite a pris un
peu de ta pris un peu de poids si on
peut y voir me défendre et bien sûr que
je vais le défendre parce que le mec est
un connard le mec qu'on va lui casser
les genoux mais qu'est ce qu'il a fait
il lui a dit tu ne me convient pas le
couple ne va pas bien au bout de cinq
mois au revoir alors il a planqué dans
un placard
chéhab à madame était enfermé dans un
placard à double toit à parois de sortir
nos marais t on à gg totalement regarder
on entend que elle en effet qui se
plaint et qui se plaint mais lui la
défense allait ou de cet homme là est en
effet il était avec moi ça ne me
convenait pas du tout en fait
[Rires]
thibault reconnaissait tout de même
qu'il s'agit quand même d'une violence
faite à cette jeune fille violence
verbale si elle entend tous les jours de
la part de celui qu'elle aime tu es trop
grosse tu es trop grossier trois d'entre
eux peut avoir pourquoi pas une relation
de confiance est effectivement dire à sa
moitié
tu t'es peut-être un petit peu laissé
aller où tu as un peu privé au travail
mais moins cinq mois de couple moi je
fais totalement la différence entre son
physique et la relation de couple à
c'est pas le problème du poids forcément
ces problèmes du couple euh vraiment ils
ne s'entendaient pas tout simplement
et ça ça ne fonctionnait pas et elle je
sais pas elle s'est mis des oeillères
c'est tout on voudrait montrer à la
séquence pour qui on peut relativiser
aussi au fait que la relation ne durait
que depuis cinq mois ce n'était pas au
bout de 20 ans non plus donc ça va c'est
pas non plus la séparation de l'année
d'accord mais bon visiblement cette
septième pièces volées voilà c'est tout
et elle a eu sa revanche donc je suis
très contente que c'est que dès l'été
dit tout ce que vous en pensez à ce qu
effectivement il ya un tabou autour du
poids des femmes comme le pensent
caroline on ne pourrait rien dire ou au
contraire c'est normal qu'à chaque fois
que s'insurge quand on pointe du doigt
le corps d'une femme